I'm Callie reading for reviewer Heidi
Kemp's you're about to learn the hard
way that effort alone isn't enough to
reach my level Dragon Ball Z Kakarot
begins right where the anime does
introducing us to Goku and his son Gohan
just before the Saiyans are set to
invade earth revealing Goku's true say
in heritage and setting off a chain of
events that threaten both earth and the
entire universe but the story we've seen
played out in many Dragon Ball Z games
over the years but unlike recent
examples Packer OTT tells it the tale by
way of a narrative driven RPG rather
than a strictly combat focused game it
gives life to the world and story of DBZ
in a refreshing way giving us a glimpse
into what life is like for Goku and his
many companions outside of battles for
the fate of the universe lies in the
balance all of Dragon Ball Z's major
story arcs are contained here but among
all of these massive earth-shattering
sagas and intense fights are numerous
smaller stories and character
interactions that many games have simply
glossed over the game structure is split
into parts free-roaming exploration
sequences with a semi open-world battle
scenes against foes big and small and
cutscenes where you watch some of the
most dramatic story moments of DBZ play
out in gorgeous and engine renditions
there's a good balance between all of
these it really feels like you're
spending too long watching a cutscene or
that you're thrust into constant battle
without being able to take a moment to
catch your breath
sometimes the exploration sequences can
seem a little over long but a lot of
that depends on how much time you want
to spend doing side quests and hunting
collectibles it's not essential to spend
a lot of time on side pursuits but it
does reap benefits and while you're
flying around the big vibrant
environments it's easy to be swept up in
exploring the DBZ world itself one
striking thing about DBZ Kakarot is how
it showcases the large cast of the anime
you begin the game as Goku but as things
progress in the story you assume control
over several other characters like Gohan
piccolo Vegeta trunks and others
familiar faces like Krillin Yamcha and
Android a teenager and combat as
assistant many of the other supporting
DBZ cast members make appearances in
SciQuest and story scenes as well Kraven
gone it's
- Dragon Ball Z is a series where
character relationships and interactions
are important and that really comes
through in a lot of the non-combat story
bits you see piccolo warm up to young
Gohan chi Chi's tough mother role the
fighters bonding outside of battle and
much more even relatively minor
characters like launch and who are have
side quests that showcase funny
interactions silly scenarios and even
genuinely sad and touching moments
seeing so many DBZ characters given
their moment to shine is great and it
helps you forget that a lot of the side
quests are fairly typical RPG kill these
enemies or collect these item Affairs of
course it would it be Dragonball Z
without combat while the 3d action
driven combat takes some getting used to
at first once you've got a decent handle
on the controls they'll be flying around
shooting off key blasts and Kamehameha
is like a pro you control a single
character with an arsenal of attacks
basic short and long range attacks
powerful special skills like energy
blasts a boost to get up close to the
opponent defensive techniques to guard
dodge and counter an attacking foe and
even power up into stronger forms it's a
careful balance since many of these
abilities cost ki which requires
charging mid battle but leaves you
vulnerable when doing so when your
tension gauge is full you can send your
warrior into a super-powered state where
you can change special texts into each
other causing some serious devastation
and if you need a little help you can
call on a CPU companion to do their own
attack it's an intriguing combat system
and the 3d aerial movement element is
unique but there's less depth to it than
it seems on the surface most normal
enemies and even a few bosses can be
patterned to make fighting them much
easier on top of that enemy variety
outside of main story battles tends to
be lacking particularly the annoying
cannon fodder foes that will interrupt
you during times when you just want to
explore the fighting still has some
standout moments particularly during big
boss fights with enemies without massive
incredibly damaging energy attacks that
force a rapid change in strategy and
sometimes even change the entire
perspective of combat overcoming some of
the nastiest things Dragon Ball Z's like
chronic villains toss at you with
skillful dodging and well-timed attacks
is immensely satisfying and somewhat
makes up for all the combat time wasted
punching the same robots over and over
again Dragon Ball Z karotz modern
semi-open approach to telling the saga
of DBZ despite some minor issues is a
good one
zooming around the environments and
seeing the world up close as a blast and
it's great being able to interact with
so many fun DBZ characters and see
stories that usually get passed over for
game adaptations and even though combat
can be a bit lacking when the big
battles happen they feel suitably epic
and engaging if you're looking for an
enjoyable way to see the life and times
of adult Goku through a new perspective
Dragon Ball Z Kakarot will grant your
wish
[Music]
you